we're gonna play a game with you we got
face mash up all right okay it's your
teammates just two of them put together
whoa oh
that's portland sudden
correct and me correct damn
tattoo is a tattoo oh my god that's
phillip lindsey in northeast oh man he
is good you're indeed i know my
teammates are the best ones
that's kind of like all right looks like
a real person that one there
oh that's chris harris and kareem
jackson man these are two teammates this
is two people well this isn't this has
adam
and who's the other one it's not a
teammate i can focus on the eyes it's
not a player oh it's not a player no
it's another guy in your organization
though it could be a coach who would be
old enough to have bag under his eyes it
looks like coach g it's zimmer i got
that what is wrong with you i got that
that's his name
endowment it's diggs and dalvin oh my
god oh that's widow
and coach yeah well coach man these guys
are too good oh that's me and dante
is that you and that's not man they
messed up your smile i don't know what
they did is that dante girly
girly oh that's golfing um
oh i got it that's cup yeah there you go
okay who do you think those two that's
me and nick that's me and nick he had
that haircut at the beginning of canvas
interesting okay so that's that's
definitely dede somewhere in there yeah
didi and shot yep there you go that's
good that's marshawn lynch tyler lockett
oh it's me and russ
that's just shaquem that's not not even
his brother in it it's both of them both
of them brothers oh gosh that is a weird
style that's me and luke there you go
shaq thompson james bradberry shaq
thompson curtis samuel ah
aj brown aj brown and logan ryan how
about logan run oh i know one i just
thought that tucker
harbaugh there you go i got it no
boom it's both of them
okay
number two brandon carr and
ah
you got half of it right in hollywood i
don't know it is that's it he's two for
two last one here we go last one this is
the tough one
me
and lj
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports